thank you for clicking on my face and
welcome back before we get started i do
want to thank the sponsor of this video
this video is brought to you by the
artist formerly known as trubill now
known as rocket money which has grown
from a bill management app to a full-on
finance empowerment tool really helpful
financial tools like setting up budgets
that automatically monitors your
spending category you get friendly
notifications if you exceed it financial
guard rails very important stuff when
you're you know adulting monitor your
credit score you get complete access to
your credit report and history rocket
money alerts you of important changes
that impact your credit score because it
was great that you found that ps5 but
you did put it on the credit card so
it's going to be like hey you should pay
that off and canceling unwanted
subscriptions is going to be that's
always going to be the greatest tool i
will always think is amazing i actually
had two recurring monthly i wasn't using
this stuff adds up man so click the link
in the description go to rocketmoney.com
john's try it out for free and unlock
more features with premium and now the
finale of better call solas aired
about a week and a half ago it's a week
and a half later so i do apologize for
that but i do still want to talk about
this i want to talk about better call
saul not necessarily the finales i don't
think i'm going to title this finale
review i do want to give my thoughts on
better call saul in general the
impression it left with me my experience
going through it generally speaking i've
done better call saul videos before so
i'm going to try to not be too redundant
and give you information i've already
given but i do want to give you my
thoughts on the show that i see as an
amazing character drama
and also it might very well be the gold
standard of a tie-in or a prequel
made from a property that's very beloved
by fans and not relying on nostalgia to
sell or drive the whole thing also
there's going to be spoil the free
review because i genuinely believe that
better call saul is worth experiencing
more importantly worth experiencing for
you without knowing how it all goes down
right even in my house of the dragon
video people who read the books like oh
you think it's this it's actually going
to be this i'm like thanks dick thanks
for telling me now i know i know
something i'm not supposed to know it's
a [ __ ] feeling so i'm not going to give
you that [ __ ] feeling but i really mean
it when i say better call saul might
very well be the gold standard of making
a prequel or spin-off without relying on
nostalgia not to say it doesn't have
nostalgia in it but those moments that
are tied into nostalgia or tied into
something that you later see the
conclusion of or the fruition of in
breaking bad these moments in better
call saul generally speaking we're
talking like 99 of the time 99 point
something like 99 and some change most
of the time it is to drive the
characters forward drive the plot
forward in a very organic way granted in
the last four episodes or so it was more
nostalgia-leaning than the show had done
before it but
i i gotta admit i did enjoy it and even
at a point there was a question a
hypothesis that was given and i was like
i hadn't thought of that but you can
tell vince gilligan and that crew like
they thought of it and they were like we
didn't even address that so i'm glad
they addressed it i really liked that
conversation like when i first heard
that they were bringing in giancarlo
esposito to play gus fring in better
call saul i was like oh yeah because you
have to do that because you know
nostalgia but it's not that i'm just
used to that because most entertainment
does that they're like we're gonna bring
in this character cause is this button
too low i feel like i should button it
up to at least this one yeah whatever
we'll go full jeff goldblum in the show
better call saul you're seeing saul
goodman's past james mcgill as he's
known back then so why not bring in mike
ermentrout but because you brought mike
in you do have to show gus fring because
mike gets wrapped up with gus frank and
since you're showing gus fring you get
to show the tension with the cartel and
how that started to simmer how it
started to really boil because in
breaking bad it was walter white's story
and gus fring there was tension with the
cartel but i always felt like there was
a much bigger story there that we just
never saw i'm glad that in better call
saul we get to see that also enter the
terminator i know i talked about la la
salamanca before but i'm going to say it
again because he's amazing better call
saul delivered a couple characters where
i'm like these are the best characters
in the
what would it be called the breaking bad
verse the better call bad verse the
breaking solvers the albuquerque verse
there we go incredible characters lalo
salamanca nacho vargas i got to say in
the the previous season or part one of
this at first it was like oh season five
is going to be divided into season five
part one the season five part two the
reason i didn't do a video on season
five part one because i was like i'll
just do season five oh wow now it's
listed as season five and season six so
i just kind of didn't do a video on a
season of better call saul the point is
nacho has this moment where you're like
he is a legend forever but also with gus
fring you get to see
how
vicious how truly mean gus fring is you
saw the mask off
in that scene in breaking bad where he
had walter white in the desert and he's
talking about he's going to kill his
family i will kill your infant daughter
and in better call saul we got that gus
fring
more for longer and again wrapped up in
characters pushing characters forward
that had to do with nacho vargas where
you're like dude you're a bad guy i mean
we all always knew gus was a bad guy but
walter white was
clearly he wasn't as good a businessman
as gus frings so when gus fring when it
was walt and gus ring was like oh enemy
and my enemy kind of thing sorry gus but
you know we're rooting for walt because
we're a [ __ ] up audience that roots
for people like walter white i guess i
guess i'm talking about this so much
because i'm still impressed with the
fact that gus fring was brought in to
better call saul giancarlo esposito was
brought in and it never felt like
nostalgia bait it only fleshed out his
character more it only fleshed out more
characters by proxy around him more and
expanded the world expanded the universe
and expanded the tension that you see in
breaking bad to where you understand it
more and i got to give some love to the
character howard everyone in the show
should be proud of the job they did
there's not a weak link in the entire
thing but howard is an amazing arc more
importantly an amazing flip well i guess
generally this video is spoiler-free in
terms of talking about
the show and the finale and how the arcs
wrap up but for the past couple seasons
there have been goings-on with the back
and forth of saul goodman and howard and
i've enjoyed that back and forth and so
i want to talk about it because it's
kind of like
you ever seen the fly you know
cronenberg's fly with jeff goldblum it's
a weird comparison but i will get there
when we first meet howard he's a smarmy
guy he looks down on jimmy miguel you
know he doesn't like him at all what can
we do for you jimmy and you're like oh
okay he's the rich successful egocentric
[ __ ] so of course we hate him and
then a point saul goodman just
[ __ ] with howard so much you're like
yeah sticking it to him yes and then at
a point i was like
i think howard's genuinely trying to be
nice to you
and now we've oh my god i've just
enjoyed you ruining his life so much it
reminds me of the flip in cronenberg's
the fly where you have seth brundle jeff
goldblum he's obviously the good guy
he's the one we're rooting for and then
you have smarmy boyfriend guy and you're
like oh obviously he's the [ __ ] we're
supposed to hate him then by the end
you're like nope smarmy [ __ ] is just
kind of
yeah he came across as unlikable
sometimes but it's because he was going
against our guy now our it's just kind
of it's flipped now that was very much
how i felt about howard howard is an
amazing testament it's an amazing arc
too just because you find someone
unlikable does not mean they're bad and
it does not mean they deserve the [ __ ]
they're getting i thought it was an
amazingly done arc in better call saul
and i got to give some love to the
character kim wexler bob odenkirk and
rhea seahorn have
an amazingly believable chemistry of
these two people who just
when they get together they truly are
partners in crime and usually in the
context of a story like this i'm not one
for love interest i usually feel forced
this one didn't i thought it was a very
well done and thought provoking
relationship where you look at them you
look at people and you realize that
there are people that feed off of each
other in a way that is just it's not
good and it doesn't mean all the people
in that situation all parties involved
are to their core bad people but that's
what i love about this universe this
world breaking bad better call saul it's
very complex writing for characters that
are not so black and white the only
thing that really stands out to me in
the show as a thing that
it's just kind of it always kind of made
me chuckle and then i would forget about
it and by the end of the show
you don't really you don't care you do
notice it the first time though is that
there are a lot of characters who are in
breaking bad who are in better call saul
better call solos a few years before
breaking bad but these characters look
around 10 years older than they did in
breaking bad because the actors
themselves yes are 10 years older than
they were in breaking bad but i do love
the continuity of the fact that vince
gilligan was like no the actors who
played the characters in breaking bad
they're going to play the characters and
better call saul the audience will be
fine with it more fine than a recasting
a recasting would be so weirdly out of
place i wouldn't have that connection
with the worlds it's a show that i do
want to re-watch immediately right now
because admittedly the show didn't grab
me until a couple seasons in the whole
time i don't know why i was like okay
it's all good man i'm like all right
come on be the lawyer saw goodman we
want to see him be the lawyer he doesn't
become saul goodman for a while i mean
we're talking seasons i think it was
season three was it season four point is
i was waiting for the wrong thing i was
looking at it through the incorrect
lenses and that's completely on me
because you're not seeing the genesis of
a lawyer you are seeing the life and
expansion of a con man and his tactics
being a lawyer that's just a thing he
did so he could better con within the
law but he's still a con man but in the
end better call saul was an amazing
character drama in its own right and i
have to stress that great characters
great world great world building great
suspense that slow burn that might be
too slow for some people but if you
stick with it you're going to have an
entertainment experience that's going to
stick with you it has fun tie-ins with
breaking bad but it doesn't rely on
breaking bad to really hold better call
saul up better call saul is not in
breaking bad shadow breaking bad is not
in the shadow of better call saul anyhow
that's my video i just wanted to tell
you about better call saul and the
impression it left with me and the
reason i liked it all right so better
call salt have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more cannot believe it's all over
what an end of an era
[Music]
you